en otros vídeos hemos hablado sobre la
diferencia entre distancia y
desplazamiento y también vimos cómo
graficar la posición contra el tiempo y
lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
usar todas esas habilidades vamos a
revisar gráficas de posición contra
tiempo y usarlas para encontrar el
desplazamiento y la distancia recorrida
entonces aquí dice que una iguana de 3.2
kilogramos corre hacia adelante y hacia
atrás en el suelo la siguiente gráfica
muestra la posición horizontal de la
iguana en metros a través del tiempo la
primera pregunta dice cuál es el
desplazamiento de la iguana entre el
segundo 0 y el segundo 5 así que aquí
debemos tener mucho cuidado porque nos
dice entre el segundo 0 y el segundo 6
sino que dice entre el segundo 0 y el
segundo 5 así que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar la respuesta bueno
el desplazamiento es sobre el cambio de
posición y el signo nos interesa nos
interesa la dirección así que esto es
igual a la posición final
- la posición inicial
bueno cuál es la posición final no
estamos hablando de la posición final de
la gráfica aquí nuestra posición final
es a los 5 segundos así que nuestra
posición final está en 6 metros
positivos
la posición final es 6 metros y a esto
le vamos a restar nuestra posición
inicial y nuestra posición inicial es
igual a 2 metros negativos menos 2
metros y esto es igual a 6 menos 2
negativo es igual a 8 positivo 8 metros
así que una manera de pensar en esto es
que está iguana cambio de posición 8
metros en la dirección positiva y pensar
en la dirección positiva es lo mismo que
moverse a la derecha serían 8 metros a
la derecha
podríamos dibujar una recta numérica por
aquí
a veces es un poco confuso porque
estamos hablando de direcciones
horizontales pero estamos graficando la
posición verticalmente aquí pero podemos
tomar la misma recta numérica y volverla
horizontal aquí tendríamos 6 negativo 4
negativo 2 negativo 0 2 468 y lo que
está pasando aquí es que la iguana
empieza en 2 negativo y durante los
siguientes 3 segundos se mueve hasta el
6 positivo se mueve hasta acá así que se
mueve hacia la derecha en 8 y eso es lo
que escribimos aquí 6 menos 2 negativo
es igual a 8
y ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con la
distancia recorrida por la iguana
durante el mismo período
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
la distancia es la longitud total
recorrida el camino total recorrido pero
una vez más avanzó de 2 negativo hasta 6
positivos durante los primeros 3
segundos y luego se mantuvo allí así que
si pensamos en la distancia vamos a
obtener el mismo resultado aunque no nos
interesen la dirección en este caso sólo
nos interesa la magnitud pero estamos
obteniendo el mismo resultado
la iguana recorrió 8 metros 8 metros
estamos obteniendo el mismo resultado
ahora lo que sería interesante saber es
qué diferencia habría si en lugar de 5
segundos aquí dijera 6 segundos si esto
fuera del segundo 0 al segundo 6 bueno
para el desplazamiento nos movimos 8
pero luego nos movimos 6 negativos
déjenme marcarlo aquí nos movimos
negativo así que en realidad tenemos más
86 si lo hacemos para los 6 segundos
entonces el desplazamiento va a ser
igual a más 2 metros tenemos 8 y luego
le restamos 6 otra manera de pensar en
esto es terminamos en cero
empezamos en 2 negativo 0 - 2 negativo
es igual a 2 si queremos pensar en la
distancia entre el segundo 0 y el
segundo 6 tenemos estos 8 metros aunque
regresamos al 0 regresamos a 0 por aquí
6 metros no lo restamos porque el camino
total que hemos recorrido es 8 metros a
la derecha y luego 6 metros a la
izquierda así que los tenemos que sumar
entonces si revisamos los primeros seis
segundos en lugar de los primeros cinco
segundos
esto sería igual a 14 metros déjenme
aclararlo una vez más desplazamiento y
distancia en los dos casos tenemos más 8
en el primer movimiento podríamos decir
y luego cuando hablamos de
desplazamiento restamos porque ahora nos
estamos moviendo hacia la izquierda nos
movemos 6 a la izquierda así que en el
caso del desplazamiento restamos 6 y
tenemos un desplazamiento neto de más 2
pero en la distancia en el camino total
recorrido tenemos 8 hacia la derecha y
luego 6 hacia la izquierda lo que nos da
un total del camino recorrido igual a 14
hagamos otro ejemplo un armadillo de 2.7
kilogramos camina en línea recta por el
desierto la siguiente gráfica muestra la
posición horizontal del armadillo en
metros a través del tiempo pensemos en
lo que pasa durante los primeros 24
segundos
vamos a revisar los 24 segundos pensemos
en el desplazamiento y en la
recorrida así que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar el desplazamiento en
los primeros 24 segundos bueno esto es
igual a nuestra posición final menos
nuestra posición inicial
nuestra posición final es igual a 0
metros y nuestra posición inicial en el
tiempo igual a 0 es igual a 6 metros así
que esto es igual a 6 negativo déjenme
repetir esto en el tiempo igual a 24
fíjense nuestra coordenada vertical
estamos en una posición igual a 0 de ahí
es donde tenemos este cero cuando
empezamos en el tiempo igual a cero
nuestra posición está aquí así que
nuestra posición final menos nuestra
posición inicial es igual a 6 negativo y
lo podemos ver aquí si revisamos esta
línea cambiamos de 6 positivo a 0 que
sería un cambio de 6 a la izquierda si
hiciéramos esto horizontal o un
desplazamiento de 6 negativo dejen de
dibujar esto en una línea horizontal
sólo para tener esto más claro
si tenemos 03
9 12 15 y así sucesivamente
empezamos en 6
hacemos muchas cosas pero terminamos en
0 en el segundo 24 así que nuestro
cambio es de 6 a la izquierda obtuvimos
un desplazamiento de 6 negativo 0 menos
6 es igual a 6 negativo ahora tratemos
de encontrar la distancia pausa en el
vídeo y traten de encontrar la distancia
que esté armadillo recorrido durante los
24 segundos esto es interesante justo
aquí empezamos en la posición 6 déjenme
hacerlo aquí empezamos en la posición 6
y permanece ahí durante los primeros 8
segundos luego del segundo 8 al segundo
16 la posición se incrementa para
obtener 15 entonces hace esto se mueve
hasta 15 esto es igual a más 9
y luego en el segundo 16 se mueve de 15
hasta 0 se mueve de 15 hasta 0 si
pensamos en el desplazamiento aquí
escribiríamos menos 15 y luego
sumaríamos esto para obtener 6 negativos
pero estamos pensando en distancia
estamos pensando en el valor absoluto de
cada parte del camino recorrido así que
todas estas van a ser positivas decimos
oye cuál es el recorrido total así que
esto va a ser igual a más 15 solo nos
interesa la longitud de estas flechas no
la dirección entonces 9 más 15 es igual
a 24 esto es interesante aunque el
armadillo recorre un total de 24 metros
su camino total fue de 24 metros de
largo su cambio neto es decir su
desplazamiento es de 6 metros a la
izquierda y esta es otra cosa que
tenemos que enfatizar este número
negativo implica dirección nos está
diciendo que si vemos esta recta
numérica nos movemos a la izquierda
incluso si fuera un 6 positivo como
estamos hablando de desplazamiento eso
implicaría movernos hacia la derecha
a distancia no nos indica dirección solo
nos indica la magnitud absoluta del
total de la distancia recorrida o la
longitud del camino y terminamos